drei spannende thema liege schon hinter
uns und jetzt geht es direkt weiter mit
herrscher
mich hat die woche bewegt die tage
vielmehr gestern dass die
linkskoalition ein fortbestand in berlin
haben wird ein weiter so wird es geben
franziska giffey hat den wählerinnen und
wählern vor der wahl versprochen ein
weiter so wird es mit ihr nicht geben es
gibt eine chance auf eine veränderung in
der stadt es gibt eine chance auf ein
anderes politisches bündnis und jetzt
das chaos wird verstetigt das chaos was
wir am flughafen.de erleben das chaos
was wir in den bürgerämtern erleben und
nicht zuletzt ich finde ein sinnbild für
die stadt die frage des wahlchaos was
wir in der stadt erlebt in berlin hätte
so dringend ein aufbruch gebraucht eine
fortschritts koalition und wir haben
ernsthaft die ampel sondiert und sie ist
gescheitert daran dass die grünen
franziska gefallen ein linksbündnis
geschoben haben das treibt mich in
diesen tagen massiv um ja und diese
koalition nehmen wir gehen davon aus
dass es die geben wird ich glaube dass
und diese künftige regierende
bürgermeisterin ist schon bevor sie
überhaupt ins amt kommt halb danieder
gesunken vor ihrer eigenen partei linken
und vor den grünen sie wollte was anders
sie hat es nicht gewagt sich damit auf
dem parteitag der wahl zu stellen
mutmaßlich hättest du das ganz knapp
gewonnen in der spd oder aber verloren
dann hat sich gleich wieder gehen müssen
wenn sie mit der koalition gescheitert
wäre aber das ist eben politik und das
ist gut wenn man was anders machen will
muss man dafür kämpfen und antreten das
hat sie nicht gewollt und nun ist sie
für mich schon nichts mehr wie hart ich
lebe in berlin und ich habe jetzt keine
illusionen mehr in diese frau die habe
ich schon zum teil verloren als sie noch
ministerin war ihr mann hat auch eine
etwas merkwürdige
vergangenheit hinter sich umgang mit
geld also dass unterwegs das taugt nix
diese rot rot grüne koalition die sich
jetzt
rot-grün-rot nennt damit das anders
klingt es ist man im schwimmbad
natürlich ist es ein sek schwingt das
ist verhalten das ist wie bei 1984 in
dem roman dann nennt man da spricht man
von frieden und meint den krieg ja also
mann mann bezeichnet dinge anders und
glaubt dadurch sei es schon erledigt es
gebe keinen weiter so in dieser kulisse
was ist das sonst außer ein weiter-so ja
und wenn ich mir angucke sie haben die
stichworte schon genannt was hier los
ist in keiner stadt sind wahlen jemals
in d stand so vergeigt worden wie hier
und das will ich anschließen die
landeswahlleiterin hat ja immerhin
einspruch gegen die zählung in zwei
wahlkreisen eingelegt weil da die
ergebnisse so knapp waren dass man gar
nicht weiß wer hat das mandat gewonnen
das ist für mich viel zu wenig ich
glaube die waren in berlin sollten
generell wiederholt werden komplett
neuwahlen in berlin denn für mich ist
nicht maßgeblich als wahlbürger als
politisch denkender mensch ob da nun
irgendwie zwei mandate falsch vergeben
worden sind sondern für mich ist
maßgeblich das hier in der ganzen breite
einer stadt fahrlässig mit wahlen
umgegangen ist und das ist die
sauberkeit von wahlen ist die essenz der
demokratie und wenn parteien sich
hinstellen und sagen da kommt drauf an
da würde sich doch gar nichts
verschieben dann sage ich die sind nicht
ganz klar im kopf denn sie wissen nicht
was sie anrichten in richtung afd und
anderen sie die afg klagt ja schon der
laden ein begeben uns sehr die zahlen
ich meine ich habe es mir angeguckt in
207 von
wahllokalen gab unregelmäßig
landeswahlleiterin festgestellt von
diesen leuten müssten hochgerechnet
62.000 abstimmen das sind 2,5 prozent
das heißt diese
prozente die wir da gesehen haben spd
21,4 grüne 18,9 cdu 18 könnten sich noch
mal komplett wenden
wenn denn jeder von denen irgendwas
anderes abgestimmt hätte oder
möglicherweise erste wahl war die erste
wahl zugelassen da hab ich will ich
sagen die wahlen sind nun absolut
ungültig aber es wäre gut tatsächlich
wenn man den mut zu sagen da war so ein
schmu drin das können wir uns einfach
nicht leider wird noch ein spieler diese
änderungen wahllokale bis weit nach 18
uhr auf wunsch die ersten prognosen über
die bildschirme linie frauen ja erzählt
eine frau hat erzählt dass wissen stammt
aus dem tagesspiegel sie hat schon einen
ausgefüllten wahlschein bekommen da war
schon spd angekreuzt und sie hat den
eigen geworfen weil sie sowieso spd
wählen wollte eva nicht gestört es gibt
nun hinterher als ihr durch den kopf
ging wie kommt das kreuz eigentlich da
schon drauf ein
gerade die längere waren 1 18 uhr waren
schon
noch mal zum focus ich meine sie hat
gesagt da war spd angekreuzt
wahrscheinlich wollte sie wirklich spd
wählen aber sie war veränderungen sie
wollte möglicherweise kein weiterso in
dieser stadt und keine ahnung was in
rösrath verzauberte rea das erleben wir
ja wehren gefährtin berlinerin und
bewegen sich ganz spannend weil dieses
beispiel das ist sehr eindrucksvoll aber
es war gott sprechen ihre these er
brauchen sie auch zeit weil sie nochmals
folge versagen weil ja ich glaube schon
dass das wahlversprechen im raum stand
dass es ein nicht an dass es tatsächlich
chance gibt auf einen regierungswechsel
und wer diesen regierungswechsel möglich
macht das war sie sie hat das deutlich
in die in diesen wahlkampf getragen und
jetzt muss man sich schon fragen gibt es
da eine chronologie bei ihr wie sie mit
solchen aussagen umgeht und welche
halbwertszeit die dann am ende noch
haben und deshalb ist das schon eine
verpasste chance und wir haben wir als
fdp ernsthaft die ampel hier sondiert in
vielen fragen genau mit dem gedanken
sich aufeinander zuzubewegen genau in
der grundhaltung die wir auch im bund
miteinander verabredet haben haben wir
das hier getan und die grünen haben für
sich entschieden dass sie die regierende
bürgermeisterin eigentlich heimlich
stellen und damit franziska gefallen in
den nächsten fünf jahren
werfen die berliner grünen sind eben
nicht die haben das wollte ich eben
grün wir sehen ja werden heute wann wir
geprägt durch diese bilder habeck und
frau berbalk und christian lindner die
mit dem modernisierungs steppe das ist
ja in berlin ganz anders die grünen hier
kommt von der alternativen liste da sind
leute er würde man sagen bin ich nicht
aber war natürlich ein trotzkist wie
harald wolf der dann nachher
übergegangen ist von der alternativen
liste und die stellvertretender
bürgermeister wurde für die damals noch
pds
und die grünen hier sind eine uhr linke
partei und die fdp in berlin hatte
zumindest mal eine zeit lang seinen
kleinen nationalen auto das ich in der
20 jahre her mit alexander von stahl der
gab es bestrebungen der aber es war hier
eine wirklich art die nicht dafür ist
dass man sagen ich sehe für modernen
kurs haben ja auch tolle kampagne
gemacht sind dafür auch ausgezeichnet
worden aber das war so und dass das hier
bei hier hat ja viel politische personal
aus dieser zeit überlebt anders als
berlin ist das eben nicht ihr durch
gemäss war oder das bricht natürlich
noch ich hab ich so ja ich habe früher
für reuters hier gearbeitet das war noch
zu mauerzeiten da konnte ich beobachten
in den folgenden jahren ich habe immer
für berlin interessiert und ich liebe
die stadt muss ich sagen es tut mir so
leid was ihr passiert ich habe gesehen
wie die hinterbänkler immer weiter nach
vorne gerutscht sind bisher am ende der
bürgermeister waren ja und da hat man
sich gewundert was wie geht das denn der
letzte regierende bürgermeister herr
müller das geht hier alles berlin so
runter weil man ist es gewöhnt sagt als
regierender bürgermeister die wahlen
müssen nicht wiederholt werden das steht
ihm gar nicht zu der mann ist nicht ganz
bei trost war ein ein regierender
bürgermeister entscheidet ob wahlen
wiederholt werden das ist eine
entscheidung des verfassungsgerichts
aber nicht sein er kann es überhaupt
nicht beurteilen er hat keine kompetenz
dafür aber pro in berlin hat man das mit
keiner holt flughafen tegel gehalten sie
hier haben sie gar nicht gesagt so nennt
so ein volksentscheid durchgeführt wurde
mehrheitlich entschieden wir wollen dass
der flug auf den theken offen bleibt 55
prozent glauben nicht dafür garantieren
danach hat man erklärt volksentscheid
hat keine macht mehr machen doch ich
muss man muss man auch ernsthaft mit dem
volksentscheid zur deutschen wohnen & co
enteignen umgehen aber wenn man sich das
sondierungs papier anschaut dann steht
da das drin was vorgefallen nie wollte
da steht drin dass es eine kommission
geben wird in berlin die ein jahr
arbeitet im übrigen unter beteiligung
der initiative die mit am tisch sitzt
und dann nach einem jahr dem senat eine
empfehlung macht wie man mit dem
volksentscheid umzugehen hat wenn die
akteure selbst am tisch sitzen dann
frage ich mich wie unabhängig diese
kommission ist und wie differenziert
diese kommission ist da weiß ich was
rauskommt das gesetz zur
vergesellschaftung das was die
sozialdemokratie nie wollte wir sind auf
dem weg dorthin kann man auch sagen dass
es schon jetzt eine blaupause wäre zu
sehen eigentlich was passieren würde
wenn in ganz deutschland rot rot grün
wäre uns vielleicht mal außerhalb von
berlin noch mal zu setzen das ist alles
sehr unterschiedlich ist das ist schon
sehr unterschied wir haben immer darauf
hingewiesen dass in berlin wie eine
besondere situation haben und wir haben
trotzdem gesagt das ist eine
kraftanstrengung sich in dieser
besonderen situation in eine koalition
zu bewegen die auch die chance hätte der
stadt mehr und besseres wirtschaftsklima
zu verschaffen dafür zu sorgen dass
besser und schneller und einfach gebaut
werden kann daß wir den
verkehrsproblemen in dieser stadt
gerecht wenn der verwaltung unter dem
30-jährigen das gefühl wenn ich
unterwegs in dem oh ja und wir haben ja
natürlich hauptstadt ja das gehört
gehört dazu das völlig in ordnung aber
trotzdem ist ja die frage mit welcher
politischen haltung tritt man hier an
und diese politische haltung die hätte
man ändern können ich find es spannend
was verlinken wir trotzdem noch schafft
damit hier fünf dax-konzerne das ist
wenn wir sie man es noch mit einbeziehen
das ist nach münchen die größte zahl
völlig verrückt da kann man sagen obwohl
hier alles eben nicht läuft gibt es das
aber vielleicht schafft es ja auch
gleich und dieses garros etwas kreatives
sein wenn das mag sein so dass sie und
das ist jetzt dax konzerne gibt aber
insgesamt muss man auch sagen wenn man
sich als bürger in berlin umschaut und
wenn man irgendwie durch die stadt läuft
muss man sagen das ist einfach chaos das
ist also das hat nichts mit einer
hauptstadt zu tun für ein ende und wenn
man sich anschaut wenn man das bürgeramt
geht oder einen pass beantragen will was
auch immer davon hast du glaub ich ja
erst wenn man erzählt berichtet wenn ja
dann in dieser koalition auch da nichts
verändert wurde also wie das möglich ist
solange ich werde jetzt mal was ein was
ich hier schon lange mal zur sprache
bringen wolle hier passt es gut ich lebe
in der mitte von berlin mitte mitte
mitte am rosenthaler platz das ist sowas
ungewitter time square von berlin viel
verkehr für junge leute die stehen
abends auf der straße vor den cafés und
imbissen essen trinken und so weiter da
dort nirgendwo abfallbehälter
aufgestellt sind lassen sie denn alles
fallen wenn sie nach hause gehen kommen
die ratten kommen die ratten von berlin
im biz im bezirk mitte gibt es keine
mülltonnen aber an ratten beauftragten
der sich darum kümmert inzwischen
dritten entschuldigen das ist berlin die
radler die nachbarhäuser 1 in einem
nachbarhaus von dem in dem ich wohne
haben die im ersten stock einen also
fallrohr genagt sind in die wohnung
gesprungen und habe ein riesen
wasserschaden wer kümmert sich darum
niemand mit israel den 100 also da
stehen diese diese grün-roten die serc
regieren stehen da und führen
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
des weltklimas und um die füße russland
die ratten das muss man sich bildlich
vorstellen so ist das sah
[Musik]